this is one of Northern Ireland's most
remarkable in popular sites a place of
science and mythology people flock each
year to see the Giant's Causeway the
Emerald Isle's first
world heritage site for some this
honeycomb pattern of 40,000 basalt
columns is a geological wonder for
others like former guide Hill dick it's
a playground for the mind and the home
of a mythical giant named Finn McCool
Finn was one of the great characters and
Irish mythology or if you like Irish
fact he had a problem with an Scottish
giant who lived 25 miles across the sea
so he decided he would go to Scotland
then McCulloch was not a good swimmer so
he used the material the volcanoes had
left behind to build the causeway to
Scotland and he called it the Giant's
Causeway with a little bit of
imagination you can find evidence of the
legends truth everywhere you look but
scientists like geologist Patrick
McKeever have their own story
they say Giant's Causeway was created by
a volcanic event some 60 million years
ago long before humans ever lived in
this beautiful corner of the world the
lava that was erupted was erupted very
very quickly and the flows were very
very thick basically if you picture you
know like wet mud in a on a hot day the
mud dries and that's a dries it shrinks
and as it shrinks you get cracks for me
and it was basically those conditions
that allowed these a polygonal hexagonal
columns to form since the 1800s Giant's
Causeway and it's nearby coasts have
been major tourist destinations but you
don't have to be a believer to
understand their allure you can weave
your own story
you can look at a rock and say that
reminds me of something or that looks
like something look way over in the
distance you will be able to and the
wonder in the eyes of these children
suggests the story of Finn McCool won't
fade away